Today we begin a slightly different
portion of our course. Uh,
we'll be talking about the periods in
the history of music beginning with the
Middle Ages,
and I've pit put the names of those
periods that we will be covering in our
course up here on the board. Obviously,
medieval renaissance, baroque,
classical romantic,
impressionist modernist.
So we could even add to that postmodernist
now and probably throw into that a
popular music in a general way.
We're going to begin here
with Gregorian chant,
talking about the traditional
music of the Roman Catholic Church.
We will not be promoting in here the
values of the Roman Catholic church
anymore.
We then we promoted the values of the
Jewish religion when we listened to
Klezmer music or,
uh,
the Islamic religion when
we listened to the autumn.
Or we will be promoting,
we will not in fact be promoting the
Lutheran tradition when we deal with Bach
next time. Uh, this ain't religion
in this course. This is art.
So with that,
understood.
Let's begin with an
introduction to medieval music.
Starting with Gregorian chant.
What is Gregorian chant?
Gregorian chant is the
monophonic one line music.
Oops, I think I need to turn
something on here. Excuse me.
Monophonic one line,
the music of the Roman Catholic church
as it existed from the time of the
earliest church fathers up until
the time of the Council of Trent,
the Council of Trent,
as you may know from your history courses,
was a conclave held in the
northern Italian town of Trento,
Italy from 1545 to 1563 at which time
they tried to combat the effects of the
Protestant reformation,
instituting reforms within the church,
purifying the existing Church of Rome,
cleaning up the Catholic Church.
In effect,
among the things that got purified
where the art and the music,
no more nudity was allowed in art,
in any nudity that was already there.
And religious art was painted over.
Any sort of secular tunes
were taken out of the church.
Snappy rhythms in church
music, uh, work proscribed.
What music was sung henceforth
would be dictated by Rome.
No more new chant was composed.
So the composition of chant then begin
all the way back slightly as shortly
after the, the death of Christ and
continued into the 16th century.
What we call Gregorian chant,
really rent.
It went on for a period
of 1500 years from this.
It is obvious then that although it takes
its name from Pope Gregory the first,
and you have his dates on the
board over there. Gregory,
the Great Gregorian chant had almost
nothing to do with Gregory Gregory was a
church administrator, a writer of
sermons, and an important theologian,
but it's only an historical accident
that he is associated with this vast
repertoire of Chin. Gregory had an
influential biographer, John the Deacon,
who ascribed perhaps more to Gregory than
he actually accomplished and generally
speaking in the Middle Ages,
there was this tendency to ascribe to
a single or a couple of male authority
figures a lot more than they actually did.
The point here is the Gregorian chant
was being composed 500 years before
Gregory set foot on this earth
and nearly a thousand years after.
What's the purpose of Gregorian
chant? What did it do? Well,
it did two things. One,
it communicated the message of the church.
It allowed for the transmission
of the word of God as they,
the faithful understood the word and
understood God and it transmitted the
theology.
The message of the church chant
then was a medium for the broadcast,
literally the broadcast of the word in a
resonant acoustical environment such as
a stone or Stucco church,
one can project,
one can impel attacks better if you sing
it rather than just simply to claim it
as usual.
I could say for example,
now let us read the Epistle of the
blessing apostle Paul to the Romans,
but the techs projects better
if I sing it. Lexi OIP sterling,
how the odd Roma Aha,
no walls
in that fashion, it goes out better
and it can reverberate better.
Chant used for direct reading directly
communicating the tax was generally sill
abic chant.
In syllabic chant,
each syllable has just one
note and in syllabic chant,
the musical range tends
to be rather narrow.
The second purpose of chant chant also
allowed for a period of reflection upon
the subject of the preceding reading.
A sermon or a passage of scripture
would be followed by a reflective chant.
Time for contemplation.
This music for reflection upon a
preceding religious theme was generally
melodramatic. Now, umbrellas,
Madec chant is one in which there are
many notes for just one syllable of texts.
And in millipedes,
medic chant,
the range tends to be a lot broader.
It's more virtuosic.
So simple chanting for readings.
That's syllabic Chad,
more complex chant for moments
of personal and reflection.
That's Mila's Madec Chin.
Let's take an example here.
I have my venerable
libor usual us up here,
and I'm going to sing the Luhya
for Easter Sunday. Listen,
I'm going to try to sing it, and it's
an example of a melodramatic chin.
And you'll notice one syllable here,
uh Oh,
um,
is conveyed by probably 30 notes.
Ooh,
yeah.
Aw Huh.
Aw,
oh, oh, oh,
oh.
So that's eight mellows,
medic chin.
A moment of joyful celebration associated
with the resurrection of Christ.
So that's what chance did.
And that's what it does today.
It just firstly a medium for
the projection of sacred texts.
And secondly,
a vehicle for spiritual contemplation
where it was chance some,
well,
early on chat with some,
and not so much in what we
would call public churches,
but more in sequestered
usually rural monasteries,
religious communities
segregated by gender.
What specifically we would
call monasteries for men
and convince or nunneries
for women.
Remember,
hamlet enjoining Ofelia
get thee to a nunnery.
The dominant monastic order for both male
and female in the Middle Ages was the
Benedictine order founded by
benedict of [inaudible] near Rome,
about five 30 common era dates and names
spelled out on the board from benedict.
The church received a code of conduct
prescribing how monks and nuns should live
the ideal spiritual life
while on this earth.
Here is that book I want to purchase.
Visit the monastery of
Saint John in Collegeville,
Minnesota about 60 miles
west of Minneapolis.
So this is the rule of Saint Benedict.
It told the clergy how to spend the day
it applied equally to male and female
communities.
The day was divided in two periods
of work and two periods of worship.
Pray, singing, chanting,
reading scripture.
They worked so as to feed themselves and
they prayed so as to save their souls.
They were not so much interested
in good works for the community.
They sort of withdrawn from the community,
but in personal salvation,
saving their own souls,
perhaps the souls of as well,
the periods during which they worship,
we're called the canonical hours.
The word Canon in Latin literally means
rule a canon is a musical composition
that follows a strict rule.
One voice has got to follow another
exactly in terms of rhythm and pitch from
beginning,
beginning to end.
But here we have something
a little bit different.
Canonical hours following the rule.
The Canon of Saint Benedict,
the hours usually involve praying and
reading scripture and in singing and they
started early in the morning about four
o'clock in most houses at a canonical
hour called matins.
Next they would go on to celebrate louds
about daybreak and so on around the
hours ending with
vespers and compliant on,
I might ask you here, we actually have
this service in the Yale community,
broadly speaking, it's not particularly,
uh, religiously oriented at all.
Have any of you gone to
the compliance service, uh,
at Christ church across from
the old bookstore? As I say,
it's not particularly a denominational
in any way. It's mostly in the dark.
It's very reflective. Yes. Michael has,
I see some other people have as well.
You might check that out Sunday
at 10 o'clock in the evening.
It's just a lovely time for
peace and quiet reflection.
You can think about any god that tuition
there I think about and perhaps work
through any personal issues that you might
want to want to engage as to the mass
of the day.
We usually think of this as the principle
service that strictly speaking was not
a canonical hour. It was
a special service. Uh,
that happened usually
at around nine o'clock,
celebrated at the high
altar of the church.
So that's what the clergy did in the
Middle Ages by way of worship gathering at
these prescribed times
to pray and to sing.
And that's what the clergy still doesn't
bend a dictate Benedictine houses
around the world.
The most authentic of these benedictine
houses is the one that you see on the
screen here.
At so limb about 150 miles
south of Paris some years back.
I had the pleasure of living
there for a 10 days, uh,
to study Gregorian chant. When you
arrive, the Abbott comes out to greet you.
He's attended on either side
by two acolytes and you go
through a ceremony of in
which he washes your hand.
This washing of the
hands was a traditional,
still is a traditional gesture by the
Benedictines of hospitality and to some
extent of humility,
you the visitor are assigned to a sale.
Let's have the next slide,
Jacob, please. There we go. Okay. And
all this signal, those. All right,
so there we are with the next
slot. You are assigned a room. Oh,
let's go back to this. A,
you're assigned a room in.
This building has been worked over,
but that's where actually I stayed in the,
in that building. In that room, you
have a light bulb, you have a desk,
you have a bed, some fruit, you
have no radio, you have no clock,
no television,
and certainly no cell phone.
How then do you get up to
attend the canonical hours?
Because in order to be in this monastery,
you are required to attend
all of these canonical hours.
What is it that wakes you up
then, would you imagine? Hmm.
Bells. Nice and loud please. Okay.
Thank you. Michael Bell's. Okay.
The ringing of the bells,
they begin to regulate your
existence for each of the signal.
Each of these canonical hours.
Indeed we get our word clock
from the medieval French word,
close bell and our word,
the very word our comes from the
Latin aura to pray or Rasia prayer.
So we have the sense of
praying at regular times,
regular intervals around the day at Solum.
The Bells call you to the church
to hear these canonical hours.
They call you to the refectory to
consume your meals and I submit that you
really haven't dined in this world to
you sit down and break dark brown bread
with 80 hooded Benedictine
speaking in Latin.
If when they are not speaking,
they are tapping particular signals on
the table and suddenly everybody will
rise.
Sevenly everybody will bow and visitor
is sort of left perplexed as to what is
transpiring. But that's,
that's what goes on.
As I have said, this rule of Saint
Benedict formulated in the sixth century,
prescribed this cycle of canonical hours.
As the Middle Ages proceeded,
the cycle of ours was adopted
at Cathedral Churches,
even though the strict rule for communal
living was not the daily timetable of
worship was kept.
But the idea of eating and
sleeping together was abandoned.
Cathedrals were much more urban in
their location. They were not withdrawn.
They were in cities.
The clergy administered to the spiritual
and social needs of the community.
The clergy was celibate de jure,
if not de facto.
They lived in private homes,
not in a communal dormitory,
in houses that were situated
all around the Cathedral.
Let's take a look at a typical
medieval cathedral. And for this,
I'm going to choose Chartron.
Now. Um, it's not typical.
It's the most beautiful.
If you have one cathedral to go to.
I strong and I think I'd been,
to all I know that I'd been to all
the big ones and in France, uh,
go to sharp for, for several
reasons. First of all,
it has the most up pristinely preserved
town around the back of the church.
As you can see,
the medieval city from the 12th and 13th
centuries is pretty much still there.
It has the widest knave of any
of these gothic cathedrals.
If you look carefully on the floor,
you see a medieval labyrinth there. Uh,
so it has the best
preserved of any of these,
uh, uh, cathedral floors.
It has the best preserved stain glass,
which is,
which is famous a world a wide.
Uh,
and it has, uh, the original
crypt in this building,
which extends all the way
back in to the, uh, uh,
eighth century indeed was part of a
preceding church that was built in the
course of the eighth
through the 11th centuries.
And we're going to see
now what the cathedral,
the Romanesque cathedral and shark looked
like before it was built into the one
that we know and see today.
This is Roman, Nashville.
What we saw before was gothic.
So here we see here we see, um,
a group of clerics centering around
Bishop full bear twos there to the right.
This illumination dates from
right around the year 10 20.
We'll return to full bear tooths and
here one of his chance at the end of our
hour.
But for the moment,
let's pass on to the
women on the left there.
Notice that they are out to the side.
They've been segregated. Indeed,
they are physically marginalized.
Women were to be silent in the church
according to the scriptural dictum of
Saint Paul.
Molliere Takei apt in a crazier,
but as we have seen,
there was ample opportunity for spiritual
contemplation and creativity for women,
specifically in the convents.
One spiritual leader within the community
of Benedictine convents was Hildegard
of Bingen.
Hildegard lived in the 12th century.
She came from the area of being in on
the West Bank of the Rhine River in
Germany.
She grew up in a Benedictine convent.
Here is the ruins of
that Benedictine convent.
And then she went on ultimately to
found her own convent. And this is the,
these are the ruins or the 17th
century drawing of that convent,
which is now also, uh, in ruins.
Hildegard was a polymath.
She could do many things.
She wrote on Church administration, on
botany, on pharmacology, on medicine,
and on music. Indeed, because
of this diversity, we can,
I think fairly say that the
first renaissance man in
actuality was a medieval
woman.
Hildegard of Bingen,
popes and bishops sought her advice
in part because she was a visionary.
She had visions associated with Dick
Christian story to go guard also wrote
Gregorian chance.
So let's look at some slides of Hildegard.
She was famous in her day here we have
a manuscript put together in northern
Italy about 20 years after her death
with the representation of Hildegard up
there on the top left.
Next slide takes us to a blow up of this.
And we see the representation of
Hildegard having a Celeste deal vision.
That's why the wavy lines
going up from her head.
She's receiving the Holy Spirit.
She is copying down. Know what she,
uh, what she perceives.
Not on a notebook computer,
but on a wax tablet with a large stylists
in her right hand. Her assistant,
the one male allowed in this
community for the sacraments.
Her assistant Volmer peaks in
astonished at what he is seeing.
A another illustration of the same sort,
the phantasmagorical
trinity here with God,
the Father Christ the warrior slaying the
devil that is now trampled on his feet
down below.
Hildegard is seeing all this as we
see from this illumination here.
And a blow up of that again
shows us the wavy lines,
the descent of the Holy Spirit,
the writing on the wax tablet this time,
her assistant,
her favorite assistant
Ricarda Ricardo looks in.
Um, again, on this
particular particular scene,
Hildegard's music is distinctive and the
texts that she created for this music
are even more remarkable,
more than any religious poet that I know.
And I have studied this to some degree,
religious poet of the
Middle Ages that I know, uh,
her tax of the most startling,
her imagery, the most vivid,
most graphic,
indeed the most beautiful.
She talks of a saint in terms
of the sweat of his goodness,
shining like a bomb on his forehead of
the odor of the sanctity of the Virgin
Mary being as sweet as the
scent of honeysuckle and Lilac.
Hildegard sees the blood of
Christ streaming in the heavens,
in her own musical creations.
With regard to them,
she styles herself simply a breadth,
a feather on the breadth of God,
a feather on the breadth of God.
What an interesting metaphor,
but very appropriate for this
very modest individual she was,
but a feather on the breadth of God with
regard to her own personal creations,
carrying out,
going wherever God would send her.
Now you have on your
cd's four hour course.
It's actually CD one track to
Hildegard's Oh greenest branch.
And when you listen to this,
it's actually the basis of a listening
exercise that we will get to. Um,
when you listen to this,
you might be interested to know that
this was recorded right in the base of
harkness tower over there was
recorded in Brandford Chapel.
And although when you read the liner
notes and we'll say the Hildegard singers,
the Hildegard singers were simply
some female graduate students,
ladies that were here interested
in singing early music that uh,
for that particular recording became what
I labeled them, the Hildegard singers.
So that recording was done
over at brand for chapel.
But let's listen to another one from a
group of four women from New York City.
They're called anonymous for they
put out wonderful recordings. Um,
and it's a good example of melodramatic
chant again by Hildegard of Bingen.
Now you have the text
up on the board here.
I don't know if we can read it then I'll
read it off to oh, Rubar Sung greenies.
Oh,
redness of blood qui are key day shell.
So ilow flew week seats that
flowed down from heaven. Quote,
DVT toss,
Tate Tate Jeep,
which divinity touched two flows,
asked view or the flower quote,
humans they to to [inaudible],
which the wintry breadth of the serpent
serpent another words the devil knew
qualm lacy will never wound.
So that's the uh,
tax. Now let's listen to the
music of Hildegard of Bingen.
Lovely. So what can we say about Chin
by way of conclusion? First of all,
of course it is monophonic.
We hear only one line monophonic
texture chances monophonic changes also
unaccompanied as you heard,
chant has no meter,
no rhythm to it,
no regular rhythm,
at least it seems to
flow as Hildegard says,
like a feather on the breath of God.
Now chant is enjoying something
of a rebirth at the moment.
Something of a resurgence of interest
ever since the appearance in 19 six,
1996 of this CD simply called Chan.
It went platinum in its first year,
selling over a million copies,
outselling the Beatles,
even for a time,
and it was succeeded by other chance.
CD's all produced appropriately
enough by angel records.
We had chant to chant three beyond chant,
son of chant. Uh, there
were Hildegard knockoffs.
We had,
uh,
Matt about monks mad about monks and if
we had the original chance CD issued by
the Benedictine monks of centered Domingo,
Spain.
So of course we have a knock off now by
the Benz Adriene monks of Santa Monica,
California.
Oh,
okay.
Let's go on to the next slide which should
be blank and I don't know what I did
with it but just last
month off here it is.
I don't have a good picture but just
last month I went on CNN online.
You know you can see the headlines there.
There was a headline move over Madonna,
I think this was the other
Madonna move over Madonna,
a CD of the and chance by a group of
Cistercian nuns is a surprise crossover
best seller reaching the pop charts and
you can actually buy this as I did on
Amazon or wherever you want to to buy it.
Why all this interest in Chin because
it has much in common with so called New
Age music chant is non confrontational,
non assertive.
It is somewhat laid back if you will,
as the mind and the spirit are allowed
to contemplate to form a divine
communion. Perhaps chant is the very
opposite of the music of Beethoven.
Beethoven tries to convince you to feel
a particular way about every moment,
every measure in his music.
It is very much rhetorical music chant.
On the other hand,
you can take on your own terms.
It is non authoritarian,
it is non assertive,
non aggressive,
it floats unfettered.
And many of these same characteristics
are found in new age music,
hence the newfound
popularity of medieval chat.
Now let's turn our attention away from
Chin away from monophonic music too early
polyphony multi voice music,
music of the Church of the Middle Ages,
but polyphonic music,
early polyphonic music for the church
was called origanum called organism.
It was first created in the great
urban gothic cathedrals of friends,
most particularly at [inaudible] of Paris.
So let's visit here.
Our well known not for dom, with the West
facade and in some of the famous, uh,
latterly edit flying buttresses
around to the south side there,
the south east side.
It is likely not coincidental that the
high walls of this new gothic style
were being created.
These courses of stone laid one on top
of the other at precisely the same time,
around 1200.
That verticality was
being introduced to music.
What I mean is that all cathedral organum
was built upward above a preexisting
chin,
bubba preexisting Gregorian chant.
The composer took the chant and placed
it in the bottom voice and then added
other voices up on top of it to
form counterpoint against it.
It was the job of the tender to take the
chance and to hold it out in long notes.
That's why the tenor is
called what it is or rigidly.
It comes from the word Latin
10 EO. I hold or 10 year, uh,
in,
um,
in modern fringe to hold the infinitive
there so that we have this idea of one
voice, the chant holding out
to the long notes underneath.
It was kind of the basis of,
of the music.
And then up above the composer
would create new polyphony.
What you see on the screen is an
example of this medieval organism.
You can see we have four
lines, uh, in each, uh,
brace in effect.
The one with V has just one pitch.
You could see the big illumination,
Their v and then the pitch f out, uh,
to the right of it.
And it just sits there
because it just holds out the,
as the music goes on for many, many,
many, many, many, many seconds.
And finally go Danay holds that out.
Then finally down at
the bottom rule wound,
as all of this other
polyphony goes on up above.
Let's listen to an example of
some of this medieval sound
[inaudible]
and we'll stop it there.
So it's very different,
but it's very complex at the same time.
Again,
good example of medieval
organ of Medieval polyphonic.
But let's turn our attention now away
from the music of the Middle Ages in Paris
to the renaissance and Rome and
specifically to the Sistine Chapel.
This Sistine Chapel was the most famous
of all churches in the late 15th and
early 16th centuries.
The core of the renaissance.
Why? Because it was the
private chapel of the pope,
not Saint Peter's.
Interestingly enough,
this is a shot of modern day Saint
Peter's. Let's go. There we go. Uh,
but this was during the renaissance,
only beginning to be constructed
following design of who?
Of, hmm. Um, which famous painter?
Michael Angelo. Yeah. Michael Angelo. I
was involved in the design of Saint Peter.
Um,
but this was not in existence at the time.
Were under a discussing here.
A big,
as an impressive as it may be.
So where the pope was actually worship
being for the most part in this period
was not in Saint Peter's,
but next door in effect over in
this building in the Sistine Chapel.
And here of course,
because it was his own place of worship,
he could come in the very best,
the best materials of the best artists,
the best musicians construction on the
Sistine Chapel began in 1477 during the
reign of Pope Sixth, this the
fourth, hence the name sticks,
Sistine Chapel.
It's 60th 16 officially.
You get the etymological connection there.
It's 132 feet long and 45 feet.
Why the ceiling?
The famous sealing Michelangelo
is 70 feet off the floor.
Michelangelo painted, as you
know, scenes from the Bible,
both creation and the expulsion.
He also painted scenes,
uh,
of the civil profits as a
written about by Virgil in the Aeneid.
The side walls are covered
with frescoes of Bata Chally,
Para Gino and Rafael here,
one by Rafael at the east end
where the high altar was situated.
There is the famous last judgment scene
by Michelangelo himself painted somewhat
later in the 1530s,
just as the pope hired the best painters.
So he engaged the finest musicians.
The incomparable is just scan they prey,
which will be the focus of your listening
exercise 16 and Giovanni pair Luigi.
Dot. Palestrina. You've probably
heard the name Palestrina,
a prototypical renaissance composer.
They composed and they sang
both chant and polyphony.
They were members of the papal chapel.
So a chapel in this period and
even today can mean two things.
One, the physical building.
Let's have another slide.
The physical building.
So that's one kind of chapel
and to the musical ensemble,
the choir that performs in this building
and the actual paypal chapel.
As you can see here,
there is a logia that sticks out.
And this is where the singers such as just
scan the prey and, uh, Giovanni panel,
VG.
Dot.
Palestrina would stand when
they sang before the pope.
Now,
because this paypal chapel here saying,
without any accompaniment, without any
accompaniment of instruments whatsoever,
even the Oregon, that style of
singing came to be called acappella.
Literally Acappella CISTINA.
So unaccompanied singing means without
instruments. If you are in an Octopal,
a singing group here at Yale,
you are a descendant of this tradition
of singing without instruments in the
Sistine chapel.
That's what acappella means in the chapel,
but literally in this pope
six stasis chapel here,
singing without instruments.
In this case,
the paypal chapel performed in the
paypal chapel standing in as mentioned,
the Logia that you see there on the
lower right side of your screen.
Who were the members of the Papal Chapel?
Well,
they were all male clerics.
We've said that chance
was segregated by gender.
There were also all female
ensembles in this period,
but they were in convents, but in
monasteries, cathedrals in here,
in the paypal chapel.
Then as today,
the ensembles were all male,
but if they were all male,
who then saying the soprano when polyphony
was performed well at various times,
this was done in one of three ways.
Males could sing in head voice,
which is called falsetto.
Any of the gentlemen here
ever tried to sing falsetto?
Oh,
oh,
Ooh,
oh, oh, oh.
Sounds pretty awful, right? Okay.
But if I practice that it ain't bad,
I never practice it.
Um,
but if I practice that you can practice
that just like you can any other voice,
uh,
and it begins to sound better and better
and it can function as a soprano line.
So that was, that was option one.
Option two was to have choir boys,
choir boys seeing this up upper part.
And as this illustration shows a,
this in many ways was a
popular medium of performance,
the old men and the young choir boys.
Uh,
but a third possibility that came to be
used in the Sistine Chapel during the
16th century West to assign the
soprano line to a cash strato,
a male who had shown a promising singing
voice as a boy and had therefore been
subjected to the process of castration
to maintain this high voice.
Now there was some economic advantage to
the Castro because one can strato could
make as much noise as three
fall status or for choir boys,
the Castro had a high voice,
but a very big body.
Now.
It has always seemed profoundly ironic
to me that the one institution most
fervently in favor of castration of boys
to produce this high powerful voice was
the papacy. But that is an
historical fact. Indeed.
The pope's continued to engage and support
Castrati into the early 20th century.
We in fact have a recording made in
1905 of the last Castrato to sing in the
paypal chapel. Allesandro Moreso
[inaudible]. His name is on the board.
I will now play a CD of this voice.
It will sound very
unpleasant for two reasons.
One the recording was made in 1905 so
it's very old and it has all the surface
noise that those old recordings have.
And to Maresca,
he himself was very old.
He was about 70 when this recording
was made and who has a good voice,
male or female,
who has a good voice when they are seven
so it doesn't present the cast rato at
its best,
but at least it will give you an
idea of the sound of this lost voice.
So we're going to listen
to a bit of Castrato.
Alexandra Marecki singing the Bach Guna.
No Ave Maria.
Okay, let's turn from that very old
recording to a modern recording. Now.
It's a recording of a piece by
Palestrina written around 1594,
the Sistine chapel here.
Um, it is a song too.
It's from a mass and for the parts
of the mass, uh, the curator,
the glory, et Cetera. See
page 83 of your textbook.
So it's a song of the mass and just
as we have the Hebrew Prophet Isaiah,
and when I think we can bring that up
now with the next slide on the ceiling of
the Sistine Chapel painted
by Michelangelo Post. Uh,
so we had the voice of Isaiah in this
mass and in this music for it is from
Isaiah that the text song to
song to song was dominus Deus,
Deus Saba, out comes holy,
holy, Holy Lord, God Almighty.
Now this piece by Palestrina, uh, and I
hope you've everybody got the sheet there.
We've got the sheet of music.
You can,
there's enough light I think generally to
see, uh, what, uh, what you have there.
Uh,
it is written in for voice polyphony,
but the aesthetic impact of this polyphony
is pretty much the same as that of
Chan.
Instead of one line of chant,
now we have four independent lines.
So we have polyphony.
Palestrina has taken a piece
of chant slightly indeed.
What it was was an old hymn
monophonic him. Should I be animated?
The line through the addition of simple
rhythmic values and placed it in four
voices so as to amplify the sense for
could do more to amplify the sense of the
of the chant.
Indeed,
this song Tucs has this same
relaxed nonaggressive unassertive.
You have very beautiful style of chant
itself even though there are now four
individual parts instead of one,
we've got polyphony instead of monopoly.
So you've got the music there.
Palestrina is overlaying sewing together
here for short chant like phrases and
I've numbered them on this
sheet one through four.
Each of these phrases comes
in in turn in each voice,
each voice imitating the preceding voice.
So we've got imitative counterpoint.
These passages of counterpoint
are called points of imitation,
points of imitation. This is what we
get a lot of in renaissance music.
So we have four points of
imitation in point of fact.
It's so they sort of look like for
very short expositions in a few,
but in this sunk twos in this
imitative saunters of Palestrina, uh,
each exposition, each of these four little
exposition has its own, the subject,
its own theme here rather than
one dominating the whole few.
Okay. So here are the EOM
saw and this is number one.
Hahahaha.
And then number point number two begins.
No me,
Saba,
uh,
number three across the page any soon.
[inaudible] uh,
and then finally [inaudible]
uh,
see in that fashion show is
we listened to this recording.
Now I have a question for you here.
Who is singing the soprano part?
Are these women the singing this or these
choirboys saying this are these false
set of sending this or these
castrati singing this? Let's listen.
Oh,
imitative style relaxed in terms of it's
expressive content is very much the,
the essence of the acapella
style of renaissance vocal music.
Uh, and who was singing the soprano
part there of our four options.
Any thoughts about that?
Elizabeth?
I can fall setters. Yeah,
there was a full meal,
false Satish voicing not women,
not choir boys and of course Castrati
or no are no longer an option.
So it was false set.
Is there now like to end with one
final final thing and that is um,
uh, enjoying myself today,
indulging myself, dressing up,
getting ready for Halloween. Um, but the,
the point of this in a way is to try
to give you a sense of what this music,
and it's a very esoteric kind of
music is about, but it really,
to do it in the classroom,
we would have to take this whole class,
we'd have to go to the cathedral,
the shark,
and we have to sit there and we'd have
to be in front of a statue and look at
the beauty of that statute. We have to
look at the architecture all around us.
We have to look at the beautiful
copes on the back of the clergy.
We would have to see the
beautiful stain glass.
We would have to smell the incense that
is light. And I thought about doing that,
but the fire marshal would
probably shut this down. Uh,
what we can try to do here,
I think I have about a minute left here
to go back to the cathedral of sharks.
So let's, we have a slide here.
Uh, it's a slide once again,
of bishop full bear tattoos.
Uh,
he is the composer of the music
that you are about to hear, uh,
and again is sung by a
female group. However, um,
and as this music plays,
just sit back and relax.
Pretend you are having a transcendental
experience yourself. Sit back, relax,
and look at some of this
glorious is stain glass. Um,
an architecture that has
been in this cathedral, uh,
since the late 12th century.
Sure.
Okay.
Ooh,
Ooh.
Oh,
So that's all for today. [inaudible]
him. Parksville beat him.
Good God.
Seal Nisa asked,
I'll turn on the light so
we don't kill ourselves.
Ooh.